So David what is the long-term plan?
The long-term plan is the council's 10-year
plan for spending and income over
that period, it's something we do
every three years. So it gets refreshed
every three years and it tells our
community how the council intends to
develop the district in terms
of council activities over the next ten
years.
It's important to realise this is
a draft long term plan so it's not
finalised and we do have to consult
our community about it and we welcome
that, because that community
it's their long term plan.
What are the big issues
facing our district in this long-term plan?
There are a number of big issues. We've
got the continuing one of developing our
Regeneration areas in Kaiapoi and we used to call them red zones and a number of
projects intended for that including
work around the Kaiapoi River and
developing sports fields and passive
areas in that area.
We've got the food forest already underway there,
which is a great community effort and
so that's to me probably the main
thing as our last few years have really been
much about earthquake recovery.
Second thing is the indoor multi-sports facility
which is proposed for our
district, to be based in Rangiora
and that will provide
facilities for range of indoor sports
and there's been a lot of demand for that and a
lot of evidence to suggest that we are
short of that kind of space.
Thirdly, and I think it's been very much in public's
mind over the last few years is our
rubbish collection facilities.
We're looking at offering people a choice, so
that if people want three bins they can
have it, they will pay for it of course.
Speaking for myself, I'll be somewhere in the middle
I'll keep my black plastic
bag because that works for me and my
wife but we wouldn't mind having the
green top bin for garden waste and organics.
So that's there as well. We've already consulted on that.
But finally overarching all that is
the question of rate rises and we've
managed to keep our rate rises fairly
low and it's also signaled to be pretty
low over the next 10 years and we're very aware that for many households
rates are a significant expense or
part of their total expenses for the year.
Why is it important for residents to
have their say?
Because essentially it is their Long Term Plan, because it's not the council's.
It's actually the Waimakariri Community's
Long Term Plan
and it's about the directions that are being set for our community
and of course as far as
rates are concerned, it's the
community that's paying for it.
How do residents make a
submission?
In a variety of ways, you can do it
online now, as you always see to be able
to do these days. Through our website,
the traditional way, through a written
submission and you can also do it by email.
And then having done that, if you
wish to speak to the council at the
hearing, you're welcome to do so.
Some people always choose to do that,
but also there will be a number of
events held throughout our district where
people can come along and ask questions
and they find out a bit more about our plans,
the plans we're offering to the community before we make a final decision in May.